- Today's the first day the
cameras are gonna be rolling
but right now I just feel
really excited and I've another
hour to sleep but I
can't, I'm too excited.
(rock music)
There are just moments
where you're like
we're actually filming this?
- Wow!
A real Carrie Bradshaw
wig, I didn't know they
made those anymore but,
why so many cactuses?
- Just the progression
from when we first
thought of that, the seed of it
every scene's a
real collaboration.
People all work together and
it becomes this other thing.
- [Director] Later,
Amy's in comfy clothes
pacing nervously
waiting for Danny P.
There's a knock on her
door and she answers it.
- Hi, come on in.
- Hi, thank you.
- Thank you so much
for squeezing me in
can I offer you--
- Extra storage in your
kitchen, offer me what?
Half a coconut water and
the dirt from your Britta
I think I'm actually
good, lonely bones.
And kind of in a rush.
Let's get started.
(laughs)
(old timey music)
- Out of my way you poor girl!
- We shot a sketch called
a porn star is born about
like a 1930's porn star.
- It was arousing for a minute
but then I was like, gotta
keep it professional.
- What's the version
of, who got the job?
Like, you're hired!
- Or like
- Well because she doesn't
know--
- So she's doing the thing
and he needs to
stop her like stop.
Like, those hands don't
need to open mail anymore.
Like something--
- We're gonna make those
hands famous,
something like that?
- Yeah.
- We're gonna make
those hands a star.
(laughs)
- Stop.
We're gonna make
those hands a star.
(laughs)
- There are just moments
where you're like,
oh my God, we wrote this,
it's really happening now.
- [Director] That's your cue.
- (laughing)
- And then after, and then after
- It's super fun to
write these things
that seem really crazy.
Just write what you would like
to have appear around you.
We wanted puppies around us.
And we got them.
- It's day 25.
Day 26 or 27th, 27th?
- I think it's the 27th.
- Like, who's not
gonna be a cunt today?
I'm drinking at
lunch, no question.
(laughs)
(cheering)
- I, thank you, everybody,
for being so good at your jobs
and for laughing and for
helping me make my dreams
come true and I really
appreciate all of you guys.
(clapping)
(rock music)
- Well we tried to have sex
it did not happen at all.
My heart was in it,
this lady was not.
(laughs)
- It's just been absolutely
incredible how much
new material she's
been able to generate
in A, a short amount of
time and B, probably one
of the busiest
periods of her life.
- [Announcer] Put your hands
together for Amy Schumer!
(audience cheers)
(heavy rock music)
(whistling)